I would like to go ahead and explain first our full year results, and following that I would like to talk about the Q4.
First of all, it was a very good year for us,...
... with the highest levels of sales, operating profit and ordinary profit in Rakuten's history.
These are the five highlights of the 2011 performance.
First of all, Ichiba surpassed one trillion Japanese yen of GMS and is still growing faster than the expanding Japanese e-commerce market.
As a matter of fact, the absolute amount of growth is increasing year by year.
So, it's growing faster than the median line and we have strengthened our international businesses especially our e-commerce businesses.
Third, we executed a very drastic restructuring project of our finance businesses...
...to focus on our high growth credit card business, and basically we expanded our legacy business.
I think we substantially reduced our risk.
Fourth, our operation was very efficient and we controlled our cost very well...
...and we expanded our global technology sites.
This is the top line growth of Rakuten Group on a consolidated basis.
Sales was almost 380 billion in Japanese yen, which is at 15 percent growth.
This is a pro forma basis after adjusting for the spin-off of the KC Card.
And operating profit grew by 18.6 percent.
Again, this is a pro forma basis and it was 75.6 billion Japanese yen.
EBITDA was a bit over 100 billion yen and grew about 15 percent.
So this is the breakdown of each business unit.
Internet service was very, very good.
Sales grew by 203.9 percent. This is the net, excluding deficit costs of the product, grew by 23.5 percent.
And the operating profit grew, EBITDA margin actually. The EBITDA margin grew by 12.8 percent.
And the operating margin grew by 13.2 percent.
The operating profit margin was 32.3 percent.
On the other hand, Internet finance grew by 16.4 percent.
This is excluding the KC Card, which had already spun off and was sold to another company.
But as you can see, in terms of operating profit margin we grew by 46.4 percent.
On a consolidated basis, as you can see after adjustment we grew by 18.6 percent. But on an accounting basis, it was an 11.9 percent growth.
It was a very, very good year for the Rakuten Group.
Edy and credit card grew by 30 percent,...
...travel grew by about 15 percent,...
...and domestic e-commerce grew by about 16.4 percent;...
...especially overseas e-commerce, the international Internet shopping business grew by about 40 percent year-over-year.
We entered into the Indonesia business.
We started the beta site of Rakuten Brazil.
We acquired the business in Germany and in the UK.
As a matter of fact, Germany's site has already changed its domain name and brand name to rakuten.de.
And the other highlight is we are going to increase our dividend payment from 200 yen per share to 250 yen per share.